guillaume la scuderia ce vous êtes
consultant militaire pour france 24
avant de parler de la ville de mario
paul les russes semblent utiliser des
bombes à sous munitions en tous cas
selon les ong human rights watch de quoi
s'agit-il est-ce que ça relève de crimes
de guerre ou d'un tribunal international
si c'est le cas alors c'est une bombe à
sous-munitions c'est quoi en fait
arrêter c'est un contenaire qui comporte
tout un tas de sous munitions de petites
bombes et qui en explosant
pollue sur des espaces et des surfaces
qui sont quand même assez conséquente
une zone pour à la fois soit interdire
le mouvement est donc ça fonctionne
comme des mines soit au contraire frappé
des objectifs le problème c'est que
c'est tellement
indiscriminée comme frappe que très
souvent les victimes ne sont pas des
objectifs militaires mais des victimes
civiles et donc c'est une convention qui
a été signée en 2008 et agréé par plus
de 100 pays en 2010 mais beaucoup de
pays n'en sont pas parties soit qu'elles
continuent elles se dire qu'elle
pourrait l'utiliser soit carrément
qu'elle soit encore pays producteurs est
parmi les pays qui refuse justement de
s'abstenir d'employer ces sous-munitions
vous avez la russie qui l'a d'ailleurs
fait en syrie alors la résistance
maintenant sur le terrain elle est plus
importante que prévu néanmoins les
russes gagnent quand même du terrain
quelle est leur stratégie est ce qu'ils
cherchent d'abord à s'emparer de
marioupol et d'odessa par exemple avant
kiev la capitale vous l'avez dit en fait
en réalité la continuité territoriale le
long de la mer d'azov elle est quasiment
gagné et la chute de mario paul
consacrerait justement cette continuité
entre les deux fronts du donbass et les
troupes venues la crimée l'avantagé
c'est que ça libérerait comme ça des
troupes pour repartir plutôt vers le
nord ça on peut aussi lire cette ce
corridor humanitaire comme étant une
première réponse à cela la deuxième
c'est que en accordant sept cette pause
opérationnelle et en faisant cette
sortie ça doit permet aussi de dire
voilà ceux qui resteront ensuite dans
mario paul selon des objectifs
militaires puisque les civils pourront
avoir été évacués et normalement
pourront être sortis à partir de ce
moment là
en fait on va skull d'une obligation qui
leur est induite par le droit
humanitaire à un objectif véritablement
cette fois militaire et qui annonce
peut-être d'autres destructions boudin
plus massive par ailleurs vous avez des
informations sur la colonne de chars de
blindés cet immense colonne qu'on a vu
ces derniers jours en direction de kiev
alors on a de plus en plus de rapports
qui montrent bien que vous avez trois
difficultés sur cette colonne là bien
évidemment des difficultés logistiques
initial on a une problématique puisque
les plots logistique sont très loin en
territoire notamment biélorusses et
russes et donc cinq premières
complications la deuxième c'est
l'impossibilité de débouchés en terrain
libre c'est à dire qu on est à la
période de ce qu'on appelle la race
petit ça la boue est donc on voit des
images qui sont de plus en plus
nombreuses de véhicules même à chenilles
qui sont hambourg mais est incapable de
bouger et on a le rapport à l'or a
confirmé peut-être mais d'officiers
russe qui aurait été même tué en voulant
réorganiser ce dispositif est ce qu'on
voit qui pourtant pèse toujours comme
une menace sur l'encerclement de de kiev
peut-être encore ralenti pour plusieurs
heures voire peut-être même plusieurs
jours plus généralement quel est leur
but ultime c'est conquérir et occuper
l'ukraine ce qui sera compliqué pour
vladimir poutine ou alors négocier une
partition entre l'est et l'ouest alors
là en fait on a été tout dépend des
succès militaires qui vont qui vont
avoir lieu s'emparer de kiev et est
important pour la russie parce que
derrière la capitale vous avez aussi le
symbole qui lie à la chute de la
capitale pourrait présager de la chute
du pays en revanche se pose aussi la
question de nous restera le gouvernement
ukrainien si le gouvernement ukrainien
kit kiev pour se réinstaller à vif il y
aura à nouveau des discussions et puis
la poursuite des opérations militaires
qui est en fait subordonnés assez réussi
cela et vous pensez qu'elle kiev il
faudrait du coup s'attendre à des
combats de rue maison par maison
alors si ça ne débouche sur ses longs
raides russes à prendre à l'un de ces
cas là plusieurs semaines surtout si la
résidence la résistance ukrainienne et
est forte on imagine dans une ville où
tout se passe bien et là on en est loin
qu' il faut à peu près un rapport de
force de 8 contre 1 pour pouvoir
s'emparer d'une ville et quand une
troupe avance 2 à peu près 1 km par jour
c'est bien pour mémoire la ville de kiev
c'est à peu près 800 kilomètres carrés
merci beaucoup guillaume glace quand
j'aurai à ce pour votre analyse merci à
vous